[音楽]
he
ana
[拍手]
皆さん
自分を
理解していますか
自分の好きなことや
苦手なこと
夢中になれること
すぐ辞めてしまうこと
私も
忠孝6年間はこんな細い体なんですけどサッカー部として
活動していてそういったことはまったく考えていませんでした
でも
大学に入ったときに
これでやっと自由になった
ここからならなんかできるかもしれないと思って
少し自分のことを考えいろんなことを体験する中で自分のことを少し知りました
そしてまたわからなくなりました
自分の好きなこととか蛍光
得意な傾向とかそういうのをまとめると
まあこの4つになるんですけども特にこの一番上のスムーズにしたいっていうのは
小さい頃から思っているを持っていることで
例えばですね川が流れていて
川の流れを遮るような石がまあそのへんにあるんですよ
こそれを石を取り除いて川の流れをスムーズにするって言った
自分の中での遊びがあったんですけれども
それはですね4時間とか5時間とかぶっ続けれ
やってたんですね
それを言語化できたのはつい最近のことです
そういった経験は
多分皆さんの中に何かあると思うんですけれども言語化できていないことも多いかなと
思います
一方自分が苦手なこと
正直
この2つはとても苦手です
例えば
理不尽な命令とか自分寮に住んでいるんですけれども
量だとも学生部と交渉とか色々あるんですけど遅いれ学生部が学生は大学の言うことに
従っていればいいんだとかそういうふうなことを言われるとまったくやる気がなくなっ
てしまいます
あと同じこともやり通じるというの苦手です結構致命的なんですけども
こういうまあ自分はたまたま性格だったん
それがば幼い頃
なぜか宇宙がすごい好きだったんですで自分の親もそういう自分の宇宙好きおすごい
応援してくれる親で色んなとこに連れてってくれたりしたんです
そして自分の今のビジョン
それが
生まれました
宇宙への lcc を作る
lcc というのはまあ ana とか jal とかではなく a
例えば東京大阪5000円とかピーチとか
ソラシド8とか安い
いった普通の飛行機会社に10分の1とか
1/20とかで英航空路線
提供している
会社のことです
今
人が
打ち合いに予行する1週間旅行するという時に
いくらお金がかかるのか
20億円
だいたい
人が一生で稼げるね等金額が2億円とか
平均で言われていますのでに10人分やっと集めてしかもそれは何も現地時代に扱わ
ないで貯めておいてやっと20億円
あ普通の人には無理です
これを僕達は
1/1000200万円にしようと思っています
200万円でもまだ高いは高いんですけども
これだったら普通の人でも
頑張ればいけるかな
本当に宇宙に行きたいという人はその夢をかなえられる金額になるのではないかなと
考えています
そして
200万円という数字を達成するためにはポケットや
既存の宇宙に行く手段ではそれは達成できないです
我々が最も現実にあると考えているのがこのつにあるような宇宙エレベーターを考えて
います
簡単に言うと地球と宇宙ステーションを結ぶエレベーターなのですが
普通の建物っていうのはまあ重力に負けないように作るんですけれども
noce レイターというのは
遠心力を利用することによって重力を打ち消して安定的に存在できるという
そういったとてつもない計画です
これが10万キロとかすごい長いケーブルでその処理に宇宙ステーションがある
そこまでこの右下のような
クライマーと呼ばれるこういう新幹線とか列車みたいなものが行き来することで人を
宇宙に運ぶ
そんな未来を僕は考えています
しかし
宇宙エレベータすごいお金がかかります
だいたい数10兆円と言われます
数10兆円というのはリニア新幹線が
崇高なんことか作れるレベルですあれが一つ
5兆円ですので
あれは何個も作るやつをじゃあどうやって実現するか
この課題に私は
また医学の1年生の時から非常に真面目にというかずっとこのことばかり考えてきまし
た
実はその宇宙エレベーターのさっき言ったクライマー
地球と宇宙を結ぶ
人の輸送機ですねの大会があるんですよ
で自分もこんなものを出しました
結構速いですけどこれで大大大 a 棟1家庭のえっと
萌え1時間とかに使いますな電気を一瞬で使ってるって結構パーを使います
でもまあこういう大会をやるにしてもすごいお金がかかるわけです
例えばこういうロープを大会だと地中で釣り上げるんですけどその地球用のヘリウム
ライトかに1000万円とか
そういうのってまあほぼボランティアの形でやられているわけで
これはなかなか永続性がないなとかでは途絶えてしまうんじゃないかというふうに思っ
ているわけです
そこで
私は
会社をつくってこの宇宙エレベーターというのを実現させるということを考えました
会社をつくって
この技宇宙エレベーターの技術を社会実装させそれで利益を稼ぎり
研究費を回してさらに新しい技術を作り
最終的には宇宙エレベーターを目指す
そんな会社私は今去年の7月ですね
作りました
私の日本になっているというのは jr東海です
彼らはリニア新幹線50年件中し続けることでええまああと10年後とかに実現させる
ようなビジネスモデルとなっています
我々も
あと何十年30年40年かかるかわかりませんが
宇宙エレベーターを実現するその日まで様々な技術を社会実装させて
宇宙エレベーター実現させようと思っています
なのでこの社名となりましたジップ
インフラストラクチャー
実父というのはロープのことですロープで社会のインフラを作る
そしてこの左のロゴ
え
ジェットあいの aino 宇宙斜めになってる奴は宇宙まで伸びる
宇宙エレベーターをイメージしたロゴとなっています
そして我々の会社でまず最初に始めたのがこのジップラインというアトラクションに
関するものなんですけどもブーブーっていうのは子供の頃そびであったと思うんです
けどもあれの500メートルとかあ19とか
長いものがまあ日本のいろんなところに最近恵方やって
えっくらいのロープを
ある意味宙吊りというか滑車で中ずになりながらゴールまで向かうんですけれども実は
これ
途中で10人に1人が罹るの影響で止まってしまうんですよそうなると宙づりになっ
ちゃうんですねめっちゃ怖いです
で子供とから萎えちゃいますでそれを助けに行かなくちゃいけないんですよ
止まってしまうと
ってことで普通はあのゴールに水るスタッフが
レス中
単位みたいにロープかって
手繰り寄せて自分で言ってまた戻ってくるんですけど凄い肉体的なロードでかつ時間も
かかるということで我々が
はい作った最初の製品がこちらになります
[音楽]
これがさっきのあのシップラインをゴール側から撮影したものになるんですけれども
コッコンドラコントローラーでこの子プラ院
立エスティマシーンですねをゴール側から
救助に向かわせますそして実際にこのような形で
ベスチューをすることができます
我々は現在このような製品を開発して販売していますが
目が一つ目指しているところとして5年後にこの技術を生かした自走型ローぺー
いうものを作ろうと考えています
ローテートすごい見た目は似ているんですけれどもロープは固定されていてそれを
モーターとバッテリーが内蔵された
それぞれの半旗が
動いて新しい都市交通を担うという
本当に新しい新交通ししているというものを開発しています
そして私が今それを
sfc で研究していますので5年後死去 sfc から地ている人がいたら5年後
sfc にいれば
湘南台駅からいせっしーまで
この二層が太郎ぺー0買えるようになるかもしれません
もしかしたら8神と日吉の駅の間もこれで通えるようになるかもしれません
本当にあの日よしてや髪のロープウェイて実現するんですよ
て
チャーマー僕は
こうやって
会社をつくって自分の夢っていうものを実現させようと思ったわけです
じゃあまあ
美奈子自分の
将来やりたいこととか
それを考えたときにそれを会社とか
まあ今流行っていますけれどもそれをつくって実現させるべきなのでしょうか
青く違うと思うんですね
本当に会社をつくってそれを運営するっていうのは
なかなか
難しく
それに適した人も本当にわずかで自分も歩調自適してないと思ってるレベルで
全員がこれをやれば良いわけではないと思っています
[音楽]
じゃあみんなが何かしらの方法でチャレンジすればいいのか
実はこれもようなんですね
別にみんながチャレンジしなくてもいい
安定した
会社の中で
ずっと同じパフォーマンスを出せるって言うのは僕はすごいと思います自分にはでき
ないのでそういう人のことは本当に本当に心の底から尊敬します
じゃあまあ落ちな目標とか思ったときに
何をするべきなのだろうか
会社を作るでもないチャレンジするべきでもない
そういう時に何をするべきなのか
岡山教
ここで喋りたいなぁと思ったのは
まず自分と向き合うことです
最初恥ずかしながら自分の好きなこととか嫌いなことをここに載せたんですけれども
23個でもいいので自分の得意なこと苦手なことをはっきりさせる
そして
何かに集中する
それよりとにチャレンジじゃなくてもいいずっと同じことをするっていうのも一つの
やり方です
そしてこれは他の人はなかなか言わないと思うんですけれどもそれ以外のことをしてて
みたらというのを僕は
提案します
私も昨年7月に会社をつくったんですけど
8ガッキー
学校の授業っていうものをしてました
まあ超母親がしてるんですけど母親にはその分の学費払ってもらってるんですごい感謝
しているんですけども
別に事業じゃなくてもいいです例えばサークル2つ持ってる人は一つに絞ってみるとか
アルバイトを辞めてみるとか
本当に何かをせてみることでより集中できます
捨てないと
一つのことをやり続けたときにどこかでこう自分はやこの分野は苦手だけど他の分野
だったらまだ何とかなるってこれ逃げてしまう
逃げると
その本当は一番最初に選んだものが自分の一番好きなことなのに他のことに手を出すと
いうのは
よくない
人間一番
一つのことに集中した時に出るエネルギーというのは本当に計り知れないものがあり
ます
バーン
この中にはもう何かに挑戦されているとか何かに集中されている方もいると思うので
その人たちに最後に一つメッセージを送って終わろうと思います
諦めなければ失敗ではない
ありがとうございました
[拍手]
ません